um i have to switch subjects because i
thought you did a great job on
mandalorian
which i think which just played a few
days ago what i'm curious about is
did you have a lot of deleted scenes
when you shot that because
there is no set run time that they have
to release so
like how does it work in the editing
room um no i mean
the script was really short the script
was much shorter than the episode the
script was like 19 pages
so that suggests 19 minutes so i added a
lot of action to just
and in fact i even asked john is that um
i said okay then my script's only 19
pages is okay they're because i cut
really fast and it's probably gonna end
up being
16 minutes right because do we need to
add more pages and you go no that's what
you're here for you need to fill that up
though okay i'll try and make that
battle longer so that's where a lot of
that
extra battle came from was just trying
to not because i knew my tendency to cut
things pretty tight so i thought
if i have a 100-page script it's a
90-minute movie so i had a 19-page
script i thought wow i'm going to run
out i'm going to run out of things
so i had a lot of action um what did it
mean to you because you got to be the
one who introduces the slave 1
to the series um what did it mean to be
bringing back boba fett and slave one
um because obviously you must have grown
up with all this oh but
this was like 12 year old dream you know
um
like when i was 12 is when empire
strikes back came out and that was a
huge boba fett fan
because you know it was they would tease
them out before the movie came out
you already knew he was going to be a
character to watch before
the marketing was really great like this
character boba fett
and so when you saw the movie you
couldn't wait to see him um
so he captured your imagination before
the movie came out that's all we were
talking about at school i still remember
that
how mysterious that character was and
you got a little taste of him
but you were waiting to see more so yeah
when i saw the script
john sent me the script and it said you
know boba fett
and dark troopers and mando and fennek
and i was just like this doesn't even
feel like a real script it feels like a
fan wrote this in a fever dream hoping
that this would be an episode
and yet this was the script it had all
the good stuff in it i it was like a
greatest hits of all the cool
i couldn't believe i got that gift to go
play in star wars with all the
the toys and get to play with boba fett
as one of your main ones
i just thought i got to go in there and
just have him be
i don't know if he's going to show up in
any more episodes or what so i got to
just make him super badass
in this moment be that character that i
imagined it being when i first heard
about him when i was 12.
that was my mission just to go satisfy
that 12 year old
fascination with the character